i've talked about some of this
if i'm a
company commander and i'm in charge of
training afghan forces
i want to do a good job
and
when i report to my battalion commander
and i you know the first i'm working
with these guys for a month and you know
he says how are those guys and i say
well they got some work to do
they're not that great they're deficient
here they're deficient there they're not
good at this
and my battalion goes commander says
okay well you know get them squared away
the next month what do i say
you know i'm gonna tend to say yeah well
we're making some improvements
we're doing a little bit better we've
got them issued better gear we we got
the supply issues taken care of that we
were worried about we did a
live fire training operation and
and so you end up
just by virtue of having a positive
attitude which americans certainly have
we end up
painting a better picture
than what is actually happening i i saw
this i i try to think if i did this i
believe i did i believe that i did in
training iraqi forces
would sometimes say what you know
um i would put some lipstick on
on on the situation a little bit
again trying to have a positive attitude
trying to look at the brightest side of
what was happening in and there was
times
in in iraq where
the
iraqis would take over a position and
the
insurgents would immediately attack it
and crush them and so we got put in
check a few times i would almost say
luckily
because that what that caused us to do
was to be very honest about the
capabilities of the people we were
working with so there is actual times
where the iraqis would take over let's
say a
checkpoint we'd say yup they're good to
go and this is when i say we i mean
coalition forces in general you know the
americans that are there said yes we've
been working with these iraqis they can
handle this checkpoint we'd step away
from the checkpoint
and this happened almost immediately
upon my arrival
this checkpoint got taken over by the
iraqis and the insurgents attacked it a
day later two days later
they killed the
american advisor that was there actually
two american advisors that were there
overran it was total disaster and that
happened when i first showed up
so it really put us in check in terms of
okay what do we need to be very cautious
about what we report up the chain of
command and when they're actually ready
but at the same time you know i my guess
is and even when we left iraq i was very
worried i was very worried when america
left iraq when coalition forces left
iraq i thought to myself
they can't they're not ready yet
and there's a
there's a similar obvious similar theme
here
so
almost every i never fought in iraq in
afghanistan but
everyone that i know that worked on the
ground with the afghan forces
were all not surprised
hey they weren't ready yet they just
weren't ready yet and it's a huge it's
it's um
it's almost like
when you have these these elements the
us support is really like the long pole
in the tent and all the other
tent poles and the canvas that goes over
the tent is and the stakes that go on
the ground all those things are really
really important and you can build those
up and you can make them really good and
you can they can provide you shelter
from the rain and shelter from the wind
but if you pull out that one long pole
in the middle
it has a huge negative impact and and
that's sort of
again in hindsight as i look at it
that's what that's one of the things i
think happened yeah i think there were
just multiple things i think even right
down to the number of ghost soldiers so
on paper there might be 300 000 afghan
soldiers when there's in reality there's
a a quarter of that because people would
take commanders for taking money of
people that never existed or they were
dead or there was no accountability um
you know i can i can go into corruption
for days in in how that
really destroyed afghanistan and
so to drill into that corruption that
you just thought let me let me see if i
got this little piece of it right i'm a
commander i'm a i'm an afghan commander
if i say i have 500 soldiers i get x
amount of money yep so guess how many i
have 700. and and two of you guys die
you're not going to report that because
you still want to keep getting their
money to the point where they would take
the bank cards of the dead soldiers and
go to the bank and get them their
paychecks every week or every month like
it's the level and we can get into this
but
in my i've never seen a more corrupt
place on every possible level
and yet
you know we and when i say we as a
united states we turned a blind eye to
that for for really 20 years instead of
going to the root and fixing it we let
it fester and create this entire
industry of corruption which is what the
taliban was not only able to capitalize
on but they came in saying
well we're not going to be corrupt and
people that don't even like the talibans
were
so fed up with that corruption that they
were going to support that even if they
didn't support the ideology